Jesus was made Lord. Yep. Acts 2:36.
Who's going to post for me so I can
answer this question?
Okay. Acts 2:36. He posted it. Let me
answer the question. Let me first read
the verse and tell you what the
objection is. Okay, guys. If you can
call me on Skype, please. And have your
Bibles ready here. Let's read it, guys.
Arthur's posting. Yiannis. Therefore,
let all the house of Israel know
assuredly that God hath made that same
Jesus whom you have crucified both Lord
and Christ. So, objection, guys. Help me
to help you focus. Focus. Help me to
help you and focus. Here's the
objection.
How can Jesus be made Lord and Christ if
he's God?
How can he be made Lord and Christ if
Do you understand the objection? I've
already done sessions on this and I have
articles on this. I have rebuttals and
sessions on this point, but I'll explain
it again. Everyone understand the
objection. You're saying Jesus is God.
If he's God, how can he be made Lord and
Christ? God has always been Lord and
Christ. No, not necessarily if you
understand context.
Are you ready? Hassan Abdullah, can you
call me on Skype? We can talk about
First John 5:7. Can you call me on
Skype? Sorry for the background noise,
guys. All right, but anyway, let's let's
deal with the objection. All right,
let's deal with the objection. Are you
ready?
Okay, I want you to focus now.
What does it mean to be Christ?
What does it mean to be Christ? I'll
show you what it means. Luke 23:23.
Guys, focus now. Don't let demons
distract you because you're going to
have to learn how to address this
objection. Luke 23:2-3. No, we know it
means anointed.
But what does it mean to be anointed in
his case? What is he anointed to do?
Luke 23:2-3. Read with me. Luke 23 2:3.
Read. Don't be distracted. Read Luke
23:es 2:3. And they began to accuse him
saying, "We found this fellow perverting
the nation and forbidding to give
tribute to Caesar, saying that he
himself is Christ a king." So to be the
Christ means to be king. And they began
to accuse him saying we found this
fellow perverting the nation and
forbidding to give tribute to Caesar
saying that he himself is Christ a king.
Then verse three and Pilate asked him
saying, "Art thou the king of the Jews?"
And he answered him and said, "Thou
sayest it." Okay, now question. If being
Christ means your king, when Jesus was
on earth, was he functioning as king?
Was he exercising his role as king when
he was on earth?
In fact, let's go to Luke 22:27.
Jesus on earth was functioning as what?
Hold on. Luke 22:27.
Luke 22:27.
Not even. Well, yeah, technically a
priest, but yeah. Luke 22:27. Pay
attention to what Jesus says. You
Yiannis. Luke 22:27.
Okay, watch here. We're going to read it
so you can see for yourself. We're
waiting for the brother to post. Arthur,
I thought you going to poke it. For
whether is greater, he that siteth at
meat, he that sits to eat, or he that
serveth? Is not he that siteth at meat,
the one who eats? But I am among you as
he that serveth. I'm here as a servant
to serve. So Yiannis and everyone else.
If Jesus is on earth as a servant.
And yet Christ means king and Lord means
one who exercises authority over
creation.
How could Jesus be Lord and Christ if on
earth Oh my I don't know why I'm
freezing. Father, rebuke the buffering
in Jesus name. Holy Spirit crushed the
head of Satan. Luke 22:27. I cut off for
all that. All right, here you go. Luke
22:27. For where for whether is greater?
Who's greater? He that sitth at me, he
who eats, or he that serves, the one who
eats, obviously, is it not he that sitth
at me? But I, Jesus, among you as he
that serveth. So Jesus is telling you,
I'm here on earth as a servant to serve,
to be a slave. So let me ask you the
question again.
Listen attentively. Don't be distracted.
can ask the Lord Jesus to help us focus.
Let me ask you a question. If he's on
earth as a servant and yet to be Christ
and Lord means someone who reigns as
king and has authority sovereignty over
creation. How could Jesus be functioning
in the role of Lord and Christ when
those roles speak to him ruling over
creation, having sovereignty over
creation, ruling over creation as Lord
and King? How could he be functioning in
those roles when on earth he wasn't
reigning as king? He wasn't exercising
his lordship and sovereignty over anyone
because he had humbled himself to be a
slave.
So could he be functioning in actuality
as Lord and Christ when Lord and Christ
means to be the sovereign ruler over
creation?
So though he's Lord in Christ,
he didn't actualize
those roles and functions until he sat
on heaven's throne.
Everyone got it now what the answer is?
Do you understand the answer now?
So though he's Lord in Christ, he didn't
actualize those roles. He didn't
actually start functioning in those
roles and all that they entail until
after his crucifixion, death, burial,
resurrection. He sat on heaven's throne.
And when he sat, he began to rule as the
sovereign king of creation. What's the
problem? Where's the problem? In fact,
Acts 2:36 told you that this Jesus whom
you crucified, well, if Jesus was
reigning as king and lord, do you think
they could have touched him and killed
him? Do you think they could actually
crucify him if he was already reigning
as king and sovereign lord?
You get it now?
Does it make sense?
It's just reading context, folks. That's
all it is. Every objection is decimated,
obliterated if you just know context and
read carefully asking the spirit to
illuminate you to understand context.
The right there told you this Jesus God
has made both Lord and Christ whom you
crucified. Well, hold on. If they killed
him on earth, then that means he wasn't
functioning in his role as Lord and
Christ. Meaning to be Lord in Christ
means you're the sovereign king. As a
sovereign king, you have the power to
subjugate,
subject your enemies, and if they refuse
to submit, then you have the power to
wipe them out. Obviously, he wasn't
functioning in the roles of Lord and
Christ, those roles were not actualized
in his life on earth if he allowed his
subjects to kill him. What's the
problem?
Is that clear? Now let's keep it over
500 guys for the glory of Jesus. Is that
clear?
But that he is Lord in Christ. Meaning
this is the one who's Lord and Christ
even though those roles were still few
meaning he is the one who's destined to
be the Lord of creation and the Christ
who reigns as king. Even though those
roles were still future and he didn't
actualize them until after his death and
resurrection. Read Luke 2:1. What did
the angels say to the shepherds when
Jesus was born in Bethlehem? Born in
Bethlehem. Notice they say, "He's
already Lord in Christ." Luke 2:1.
Luke. For unto you is born this day in
the city of David, a Savior which is,
not which will be, which is Christ the
Lord.
Notice when he was born.
Born Christ the Lord.
You got it.
Did that make sense?
Hello.
>> Hello. Hi, Sam.
>> Who is this?
>> My name is Santiago.
>> Hey, what's up? You just asked me if you
can call me. Now, before you ask me a
question, let me just finish this point
real quickly.
>> Sure.
>> Okay, you guys got it. The angels told
the shepherds when Jesus was born in
Bethlehem, born to you in the city of
David is not who will be. He is Christ
the Lord. Though he's Christ the Lord,
he didn't actualize
those roles until his ascension when the
father honored him and exalted him. Did
it make sense? Now, before I take this
brother's question,
did it make sense for every one of you?
Before I move on,
I just want I don't want to move on
until it makes sense.